[Music]
on this wednesday night
overwhelmed and under fire alberta's
vaccine booking system
buckles all of a sudden it says server
is not
available as confusion spreads over a
patchwork of plans throughout ontario
international travelers ignoring hotel
quarantine orders why police
won't stop them potential new hope about
the fate
of the two michaels plus powering the
nhl forward
i was just wanting to get hired i i
wasn't thinking about
you know being the first black official
and calling out
offside behavior both on and off the ice
the inspiring and historic career
of jay sharers
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
as more vaccines are delivered to canada
the pressure is on the provinces to
administer them and
in some places it's not going smoothly
in alberta the online booking system was
overwhelmed shortly after it went live
at 8 00 a.m
people aged 75 and older there are
eligible to be vaccinated but many
albertans complained
they couldn't access the site each
province has
their own strategy and criteria for
vaccine rollout and the number of doses
being given
is slowly on the rise more than 1.16
million canadians have now received at
least one dose of either the pfizer
biontec
or moderna vaccine 40 percent of them
more than 470 000 people
have received the second shot and are
now fully vaccinated
ontario and quebec have administered the
most doses more than
600 000 in ontario and more than three
hundred thousand
in quebec the vaccine rollout is in a
race with the more transmissible
variants
cases of those are on the rise in a
number of places in canada
quebec reported a 24 jump in presumptive
cases involving variants of concern
in just 24 hours it's a concern too in
ontario toronto health officials say
200 additional suspected cases of
variants have been identified
in the past two days the provinces have
had months to work on getting their
systems and people in place to
administer the vaccines
in our top story tonight abigail beeman
looks at how it's going
so far just a little wheel goes around
and then all of a sudden it says
uh servers not available when alberta's
vaccine bookings opened at 8 a.m
for seniors 75 and older gary mason
was ready the system wasn't
i had two phones going too i also phoned
the 811 number on my slant line and my
cell phone
and the first day they just they just
kept bringing business we expect there
will be enormous demand for immunization
we have increased staffing for
healthlink to make sure that any senior
who wants an appointment
can get an appointment as quickly as
possible but we know this will take
weeks to achieve
they put up their website bang it's
crashed we want to make sure
we nail this we have it down pat ontario
plays defense over criticism
its booking website won't be live until
march 15th
certain eligible vulnerable people can
make appointments this week
not just in alberta but quebec and
manitoba too
first nations people in manitoba older
than age 75
can now make appointments wednesday
ontario announced a few new details
those 80 and older can book the third
week of march
75 and up can book april 15th 70 and
older may 1st and so on we will be able
to start with essential workers
the first week in may but exactly who
qualifies hasn't been decided
and since the 34 public health units are
tasked with coming up with local plans
the details become more confusing ottawa
for example is launching its own booking
portal
first and starting vaccination for those
80 and older in the hardest hit
neighborhoods march
5th 10 days earlier than the
province-wide plan
we are once again leading the province
in providing the vaccine to our
residents
british columbia is also facing
criticism for being slow
it's promising more details on monday
especially for those
80 and older the top doctor says bc has
more seniors than alberta
ontario's premier used a similar line
saying ontario
in general has a much larger population
than alberta
but vaccines coming from ottawa are
generally allocated on a per capita
basis abigail beeman global news ottawa
there is some potentially promising news
about the johnson and johnson
single dose vaccine scientists at the
u.s food and drug administration
reviewed data and
have concluded the vaccine is safe and
effective and prevents hospitalizations
from covet 19.
johnson and johnson's own studies found
it has varying degrees of effectiveness
against
the variants but overall is 66 percent
effective
the fda meets on friday to decide
whether to authorize emergency use of
the johnson johnson vaccine
health canada is still reviewing it
canada has pre-ordered
10 million doses of it to try to limit
new infections from entering the country
new rules are in place for air travelers
but some passengers seem to be skirting
them international travelers are now
required to quarantine for three days in
a government approved hotel at their own
expense
but how exactly is that being enforced
shawn o'shea is looking into that for us
tonight
donna the new airport quarantine rules
rely heavily on the honor system
when travelers touched down in canada
they're supposed to go to a designated
hotel
like this one but they're not forced
since monday morning it's the law
international passengers arriving in
vancouver
calgary montreal and here in toronto
must go straight from the airport
into a quarantine hotel whether they
like it or in this case
not i literally have no choice i don't
want to
be here the new rules have few fans
three day
hotel quarantine it's a joke but defying
the rules wouldn't be right this
canadian traveler told us
no i don't want to break the road
because everybody has to be safe
you know i know they're doing it for a
reason and you know
we all have to do our part but police
admit that on monday and tuesday some
travelers did refuse
the federal government has now put in
place quarantine measures that are
designed to protect our community
it's unfortunate that that what you're
describing might be occurring
some on social media saying they'd
rather pay a fine than obey
and i hope that people do abide by the
new stricter guidelines when it comes to
your responsibilities but if someone
doesn't choose to follow the rules here
at pearson airport
police won't stop them enforcement is
entirely in the hands
of the public health agency of canada
which declined our request for an
on-camera interview
up until sunday peel police handed out
49 tickets to travelers
who refused a mandatory covet 19 test at
the airport
that's an 880 provincial fine but now
with the stricter hotel quarantine in
effect
they're not charging anyone someone
could ignore the quarantine rule and
just go home
tempting some say i feel like it
but you risk a three thousand dollar
fine or more the cost of breaking the
federal quarantine rules
and even though police won't stop you
here government inspectors could find
you later
this woman says the quarantine isn't so
bad three days it's okay
not 14 days you must stay at the
quarantine hotel
until the results of the airport
quarantine tests come back
and the balance of that 14 days at home
inconvenient
pricey unpopular but most travelers are
doing it donna
all right shawn o'shea in mississauga
tonight thanks a security guard hired to
do quarantine compliance has been
charged with sexual assault and
extortion
after an incident at a woman's home in
oakville ontario halton regional police
say the accused a 27-year-old hamilton
man
demanded the woman pay a fine in cash
and when she refused it's alleged she
was
sexually assaulted police say the man
worked for one of four
private security firms hired to enforce
the mandatory 14
14 day quarantine requirements
authorities are concerned there may be
other victims and they are appealing for
them to come forward
new information is always emerging as
vaccines are rolled out and now france
is considering whether giving
a single dose instead of two to people
who have already had covid19
would keep them from being re-infected
that could free up millions of doses
preliminary data is showing some promise
but at this point the research is
limited
crystal commancing looks at what we know
and don't know
every jab is providing protection
against covid19
officials in england shared data from
two studies showing reduced
disease with a single shot and a 75
percent drop in hospitalization and
death in elderly people
overall we're seeing a really strong
effect to reducing
any infection asymptomatically
symptomatic this is the first time that
this has been done the symptom
in a systematic way for the pfizer
biontech vaccine
with more being learned about the
vaccines france
is looking to try something new the
country's health minister is expected to
decide
soon if people who have had the virus
will get just
one shot everything we're doing in terms
of vaccine doses
is safe in terms of people taking it um
the risks are largely in the other
direction
is this going to be sufficient to
protect the person who gets vaccinated
in the long
term two small studies from the u.s out
of mount sinai medical school in the
university of maryland
showed a single dose in people who have
already contracted covid19
provided at least the same amount of
protection as
two shots in people who haven't been
infected
the data has not been peer reviewed
if france makes the switch to a single
dose it could
maximize vaccine supply the reality is
and we've seen in canada you know we are
at the level of resource
scarcity when things supply chains dry
up and that type of thing so
you know there is something to be said
about doing this
citing evolving knowledge the health
authority in france updated its opinion
saying those who have been infected
should wait a minimum of three months
before getting a single shot collecting
this data now in real time
is going to be super important for the
rest of the world to get the most
optimal vaccine strategy
it doesn't appear any other country is
considering this strategy
for people who have had the virus
crystal gamansen global news
london prime minister trudeau faced
questions today about whether he was
briefed about allegations against
canada's former top soldier
general jonathan vance is accused of
inappropriate behavior with two female
subordinates
the defense minister has said several
times any information that was brought
forward was taken to the appropriate
authorities
today the prime minister said this i
first learned of allegations against
general vance
in global news reporting we have no
tolerance for any form of sexual
misconduct we have launched
an independent investigation and we have
confidence that it will
go underway appropriately one of the
women accusing vance has spoken to
global news major kelly brennan claims
she was involved in a long-standing
intimate relationship
with him vance denies all allegations
prime minister trudeau's meeting
yesterday with the u.s president joe
biden has raised hope about the fate
of the two michaels michael kovrig and
michael spavor who have been in custody
in china for more than two years
biden named the two men and said he
would work with canada on getting them
released
what does that mean in practical terms
though david aiken looks into what
action
might follow biden's words human beings
are not
bartering ships it was the strongest
statement
yet from canada's most important ally a
u.s
president mentioning by name the two
canadians
michael spavar and michael coving
covering excuse me detained in
retaliation for the 2017 arrest
by rcmp of huawei executive mong wang
zhou
on a u.s extradition warrant kovrik's
sister ariana bootsa seen here with her
brother
listened carefully to the president and
told global news on wednesday that
biden's words were music to my ears but
i've been listening to statements
commitments and pledges
for over two years yet nothing has
changed for the better for my brother
or michael spavor i do have more hope in
this administration
attempting to follow through on securing
their freedom but for now
they are still just words the government
of china currently dismissed
biden's comments with a spokesman saying
china's
judicial sovereignty allows no
interference still
china watchers say biden's intervention
is significant so that was very strong
language and
and that means that there's going to be
a new and
strong voice for their release
and so that's very welcome biden must
now follow up and continue to press the
case of the two michaels
whenever he meets chinese leaders i
think what we're seeing
is that china is finally getting the
message that there are costs
and consequences to their actions one
thing biden cannot do
is press his justice department to drop
the case
against monk that case is being handled
by an
independent judicial process on both
sides of the border
and even if this case was resolved and
hmong was free to return to china
experts say there are no guarantees
china would quickly or
automatically release the detained
canadians
as for the two michaels on wednesday
they marked
807 days in a chinese prison
david aiken global news ottawa
the future is also uncertain tonight for
tiger woods doctors say he is lucky to
be alive he's recovering from emergency
surgery
after his vehicle went off the road and
rolled down an embankment in california
the 45 year old was alone in the suv
when it veered off the road south of l.a
trauma specialists inserted a rod to
stabilize his right tibia and use screws
and pins to fix his foot and ankle bones
woods is said to be awake and responsive
he was heading to a golf course to give
celebrities golf tips
when the crash happened the airbags did
deploy and he was wearing a seatbelt he
was extricated through the windshield
i don't think he was aware of how
gravely he was injured at the time
it could be a mixture of adrenaline it
could have been shock
the l.a county sheriff says it appears
woods may have been speeding
they have no evidence he was impaired
a collapse caught on camera coming up
the moment the ground buckles
at a cemetery
canada and the u.s held high-level
meetings today on climate policy
u.s president joe biden has called
climate change the existential threat of
our time
and has put the issue back at the top of
the american foreign policy agenda
it is a sharp contrast to the past four
years former president trump often
ignored or
mocked climate science jackson proskow
reports on the shift in tone
and what it could mean for canada u.s
leadership has been
sorely missed over the past past
years the virtual meeting between
president and prime minister thank you
mr prime minister ended with a promise
to tackle the real world problem of
climate change together
canada and the united states are going
to work in lockstep
to display the seriousness of our
commitment at both home and abroad
work that continued behind closed doors
wednesday as high-level delegations from
both countries
met to work on common policies and
shared targets
it's a wonderful thing to have the
americans back at the table
being thoughtful progressive and
ambitious with respect to climate action
early plans include potential north
american vehicle emissions standards
carbon taxes on imports from polluting
countries
and overall emissions reductions meant
to stop temperatures from rising beyond
1.5 degrees celsius
the climate tipping point this road map
sets
an a very strong first step for both
countries to work together
on a fairly ambitious agenda of re you
know reshaping our economies
around a rapid transition to clean
energy a canada
u.s climate pact is a dramatic shift
from the past four years
we're going to cancel the paris climate
agreement when president donald trump
turned his back on international
obligations
it is time to start treating the climate
crisis
like the urgent security threat that it
is
the biden administration has appointed a
first ever u.s
climate envoy who this week brought his
message to the u.n security council
in a bid to sway other nations too i am
convinced
it is literally our last best hope to
get on track
and to get this right the trudeau
government insists working with the us
is also meant to send a message to the
world how canada
and the united states could work
together to help other countries raise
their level of ambition
for now there is a promise to develop
new promises more concrete goals could
be announced as soon as april
with the hope that binational
cooperation makes it harder for either
nation to walk away from commitments in
the future
simply because of a shift in the
political winds
jackson prosco global news washington
getting back into sheep shape still
ahead a desperately needed makeover
you might say this guy is having a bad
hairdo hair day rather rescuers in
australia named this sheep
ba rak they retrieved him from a forest
where he'd apparently been running wild
for a while
by the time his makeover was complete
he'd lost 35 kilograms of fleece he's
now got
a new coat and is settling in with other
sheep
at a sanctuary in italy something
extraordinary happened part of a
cemetery has
collapsed it's believed the landslide
was caused by coastal erosion
aggravated by severe weather only 10 of
about 200 coffins have been recovered
the surrounding area has been secured to
stop any more from drifting away
a video shot by cemetery workers
captured the moment it happened
drones are now being used to assess the
damage and monitor
the stability of the remaining slope
breaking barriers next the bc man who
made pro hockey history
some milestones are better recognized
late than never
it took many years for the national
hockey league to honor willie o'ree he's
the maritimer
who became the first black player in the
league well now
another trailblazer from the town of
hope bc is being recognized
jay sharers was the first black linesman
and the first black official in the nhl
and he played an important role in
making the game more diverse
ross lord has his story the passing of
time has helped jay
sharers reconsider his part in breaking
a color barrier in pro hockey
when i first got hired by the nhl i was
just wanting to get hired i i wasn't
thinking about you know being the first
black official in a position of
authority over athletes and coaches
many of them were used to seeing people
of color in lesser positions
his pioneering achievement in 1990 was
barely acknowledged publicly
also never mentioned was how he stared
down racism
like verbal abuse from fans mostly in
lower leagues than the nhl
and even hurtful comments from his
officiating colleagues
there was definitely things said
sometimes in the locker room that were
unwarranted or insensitive rather than
confront them with anger
sharers chose to educate others about
the damaging impact of their words
that you don't realize how hurtful that
is or what kind of pain that represents
to things that my father went through
when he immigrated from jamaica to
canada
and being married to a white woman in
the late 50s early 60s
that you just can't say those things
after officiating 2
000 nhl games including the stanley cup
finals and retiring in 2017
sharers is proud he excelled in a
grueling job that eventually forced him
to get a hip replacement
along with pride there's obligation i
definitely feel a sense of
responsibility in terms of
how i might be a role model for
a young boy or girl who would look
and see me and say well i look like him
maybe there's a possibility or a chance
that i could do it that's exactly what
happened
the guy's a little bit of a legend in
our business um
and and especially for for me shandor
alfonso says sharers inspired him to
become
the nhl's second black on ice official
jay didn't have anyone to
to look up to in his exact career coming
up so he kind of paved the way for us
and and let us know that's possible
sharers plans to promote officiating in
his adopted home of st
louis hopefully attracting a wider range
of prospects
to the job he loved ross lord global
news
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is from nova scotia
the official african nova scotian flag
went on display at government house last
night for the first time
it has been years in the making and was
unveiled last week to mark african
heritage month
it will be on display at government
house for special events
the new design features a stylized
sankofa which symbolizes the need to
learn from the past
to build a successful future thanks for
watching
take care of yourselves bye-bye